hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
we're gonna start out with a game called
tonsil terror now this might be the most
innovative game I hesitate to say
innovative because I'm gonna assume this
just gonna be weird it's if it's a game
that's built off of you screaming and me
I'm a good scream guy I know how to
scream real good I know the screams I do
scream I scream real good you don't play
as a human I think you play as a tonsil
in a human and well you'll see all right
you'll see what I mean in just a second
okay I think I've got the scream level
where it should be so I'm going to start
this your your it's connected to your
microphone so oh I gotta play real
close-up on it I gotta play real up on
it okay so yeah okay I don't to be
screaming into oh so what
[Music]
[Applause]
oh so you're looking for so you're
looking for candy here so you're looking
for candy and oh and the only defense
against the ghost is screaming well I
didn't work all right so well I can also
do as I can find it I can bind it to a
button Oh both OH both is good both is
good okay
we're gonna do both so really once the
guy gets you there's really no way to go
about it for educational use only yes I
assume this game is very educational
about the interiors of the mouth okay so
I'm assuming I'm supposed to again
there's a piece of candy candy Bob oh
really it's just good stuck in my teeth
[Music]
I'm supposed to do this is it like am I
not screaming loud enough cuz I'll
scream louder I'll do it all hurt this
is the worst first game the start is a
whole day of recording them - it's the
worst first game cuz this is gonna blow
out my voice like it the very alright I
can do this don't know if it's like wow
that's good everyone cover their ears
it's gonna be
[Music]
oh I can't go faster than that what am I
supposed to be doing oh oh yeah
oh ah they don't like the screaming oh
so I'm supposed to just be nice and call
candy okay so I'm getting it now and it
flashes when there's candy nearby no I
think maybe not yes there we go okay all
right okay uh hey buddy
[Music]
ah where's there's a hole [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay I'm
a fine I'm a fine I'm a fine I'm a fine
I'm fine
okay I don't think this sounds like
you're the game but I'm playing it this
way Oh didn't Oh
oh I wish I'd kept the button on now I
have no idea where to go oh I wish I'd
oh I wish I'd kept the button on I love
them
tonsil physics or the uvula physics
that's what I really want out of game
good uvula physics four of eight ah ah
five they're really gonna give me this
time I don't know how or why no candy
here
no I don't know where I'm going
what's down there where did I come from
down here I don't remember oh I see my
way a circle blue
let me get real
[Music]
nod [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
ah there's so everywhere they're
everywhere they move even when I'm not
ah oh yeah they do okay I think you guys
stop this game just for my own sanity
but that's funny that's a clever
mechanic
well can I say a little bit of a sweet
tooth I got a sweet tooth I'm gonna try
another game all right so this is
Isabelle now I don't know what East
sub-l is about but we're going to find
out am i waking up again oh I am okay
cave this time no comfy bed for me oh
it's a bright sunshiny day did I fall in
a hole Oh someone give me a can of beer
I've got my good weapon here hello hello
yeah Oh another tome love me custody
who's laughing at me who's laughing at
me you know who the hell I am
you'd better not I mean you better yes I
mean you probably do I don't know
my name is markiplier no matter what
that's who I am
hello thought I saw some hold it there
can I pick this up oh yeah I can yes
this is like no light at all I might as
well not be having this what is
moderately creepy so who put all this
stuff up here this definitely isn't a
mine I hear something
all right this definitely isn't a mine
something else going on here it's open
Abul no not yet anyway all right
I can't sprint so this is my maximum
speed unless it's gonna get to a chase
sequence and then unlock sprint for me
which is something with these douches
who make these or games sometimes want
to do oh hello what a put an ugly key I
mean I'm sorry I don't usually insult
keys that way but this key is just blood
ugly whatever here we go your junk just
that easy huh did it is it open it open
ah I got a right-click okay I get it
okay so far so I did oh [ __ ]
oh hi Oh No thank you I don't why I
bought Girl Scout cookies already hello
how are you Oh another Tom surrounded by
weird floating skulls perfectly normal
bye oh there why and do I need this I'm
gonna assume that I do even though I
haven't needed any tomes up until this
point oh grandma hi how are you doing
hey grandma come back on your back ain't
so good you should lie down
oh that's something I can't see anything
that way I'm not gonna
that way and I want to be out here hello
oh good it's locked and I didn't bring
the key so is there something down there
grandma you can see grandma
no grandma did you say you could smell
me I know I haven't bathed in a while
grandma but that doesn't mean you need
to call me out like that I don't know
where something there there is something
there I need to go get like a candle or
something but maybe one of these skulls
I could put a candle and make a nice
candle holder Allah the forest okay
weird but I highly doubt that the key is
gonna be the same key across the board
but I guess there's no harm and bringing
it just in case and it's gone oh that's
right it would be gone because it would
it was stuck in the door so let me bring
let me bring this at least it's gonna
help a little bit anyway
spooky I don't know I can't see anything
Oh Oh grandma you didn't tell me soup's
on
oh boy grandma oh I see a key can't see
it see it right there okay
all right I got key I sure did I sure
did I got the key here we go
right in the hole I'm gonna grab that
candle I ain't gonna be left alone in
the dark anymore okay grandma I'll come
back ain't hungry right now I know I
know I'm all skin and bones
it's gettin sweet succulent bones but a
hard past grandma it reminds me of the
inner caves from the forest I just gotta
find keys and unlock doors you know the
one where if you get caught by the
cannibals you wake up in that cave those
cannibals sure are very forgiving I
don't like these no I don't want you oh
okay
so the ghosts around here throw tantrums
and throw these chairs all willy-nilly
like okay I can't carry both of these so
here we go then I would like to state
for the record that I hate this I just
want everyone to know that this is the
worst I just want everyone at home to
understand that I don't appreciate
what's happening here it's too quiet why
is it quiet all the way out oh sure
that's good I'm sure I won't be stabbed
in the back before I go home oh boy it
does dee-dum oh I didn't know I could
read these don't turn around
by don't worry I'll take the advice I
could turn around I know better than
that even though I just did okay goodbye
goodbye my ankles Oh Oh blast that's not
good that's that's not good yeah it's
not good dad dad's not good you do that
to me I didn't eat your soup but that's
okay
all right fine grandma if you're gonna
be that way I knew they were gonna do
that but I do bother grabbing my ankles
like that huh
all right oh this was made by a twitch
developer oh that's so cool Oh
someone someone made this lives live on
stream oh that's cool that was really
neat Oh a very basic horror experience
but sometimes basic horror is what you
really need because that did it pretty
well I mean it's like not innovative
it's not innovative in a lot of ways but
it is very true to form of good horror
like it created the environment it
created the slow pacing it didn't really
give me instructions of what to do but I
could figure things out I didn't know I
could open the books from the very GetGo
because they didn't understand the
controls but at the same time like even
though I got it on the last one which
was important so there you go next thank
you
next all right now bear with me because
the title is real weird seven or ja
seven seven or just seven savanna just
seven I am not supposed to stay in this
homestay it's haunted she trying to kill
me in my dream I need to get the hell
out of here oh please God help me God
can't save you nobody oh oh Megadeth
Metallica Metallica sombody likes music
nothing's here
sleep yet that doesn't seem right okay
oh boy hey wait a minute
hey hang on a second final thing or two
about ominous clothes coming out of my
own house that's probably a bad thing
also why what does my door not go all
the way up oh whoa okay all right well
I'm uh I'm waiting I'm waiting to be Wow
whoa
aha who-who do I live with 3d game art
for phone and unity it's a radio
no copyright know that no thank you
if it's locked
[Music]
okay well well go to sleep then right
what do I get
what are you doing what's going on
huh oh well well alright then I guess
that's all there is
it's a sink you're right it is nothing's
here nothing's here nothing's here
nothing's here okay I got a whole house
full of nothing which is always good
that was moderately disconcerting and I
kind of liked the fact that it didn't
pay off into a cliche jump-scare God
dang it dang cool really I've got a
keypad to a door in my own home
okay I'm down to clown for that okay all
right but just that one drawer just just
as one drawer which is just that one
thank you okay all right anyway I'm down
to clown not available in this demo oh
this is just a demo okay a demo huh all
right then maybe not oh maybe yeah my
bladders about to blow anybody in here
maybe like there's clues in the the the
environment or something dunno ooh hello
five five baby COS of five oh hell yeah
nowadays people prefer scrolling their
phone rather than reading books
sad but true oh my god this is our I'm
14 and this is deep five books here Oh
901 this is the greatest McGinnis
there's another one what have we got a
little crouched down it nope I can't
pick her up there three okay I am on my
dirt seize the tippy-top seize of my
Tutsi what seize I am so ready
whatever the hell this is getting in me
in store for let's do this baby what
else we got
I am burnin up this place in here no not
yet no we'll save that for later oh I am
jazz riled up to my testes here we go
come on what do we got here oh here we
go on the fridge five nine one three
nine okay good great love it love it
Lots super love it look what there it is
there we go five nine one three nine
four love it love it lots just one more
on the kitchen table you know it baby I
can't wait
[ __ ] oh god I didn't even know daddy no
I didn't know I was here making jokes
god damn it damn you six do you think
you're just gonna jump scare me like
that you douche it's always the simple
ones because I get lulled into a false
sense of security
dammit five nine one three nine four six
enter
oh my god that was it all right okay all
right no no nope no no no no no no
listen listen listen listen that was
fine
that was fine one jump-scare that's fine
but I don't think that was quite enough
so I'm gonna do one more game
just because I think it's only fair so
we're gonna do one more cuz that was
only it worth like one jump-scare so I
can't really say that that was a proper
trial of a game so this one's called
Nosferatu's lair of doom made by good
old Dave microwave Oh No lot okay
Clarence's well we made it
downtown LOX chasm wait or is it no SWAT
oh who cares anyway I'll go inside the
lawn if anything bad happens or ring the
bell at the top of the castle to signal
for help
got it wait why would you go in alone
why are you gonna go it alone we came
here together why not stick together
split up is bad you go in alone you die
how do you even get to the top of the
Bell Oh No he's so brave look at him go
oh well [ __ ] that's that's a problem
that's problem the hat back why don't
you going alone you ain't alone YouTube
okay
well then oh I'm the idiot oh well I
suppose I'm in trouble
well why does that keep happening there
we go a much battery all right well
let's do this whatever just got to get
to the top of the castle that all we got
to do was a you know spur our - okay I
don't know how to get that top atop okay
I suppose a creaking alright then is
this all I got to do
hey who you who you alright why why what
did I do
I didn't mean to do it whatever I did I
didn't do it
being that I don't know why you thought
that that was a necessary thing but doe
someone someone did something naughty on
this floor okay so I gotta get to the
tippy-top again and signal for help
whoa hmm this ladder is broken off to go
and find some ladder rungs to replace
the broken ones or or you could climb up
the bookshelf whoa
aha I can thank this ladder put it on
that ladder and make life a lot easier
to us me that girls I move this bike
whoa whoa you can't crawl under here can
you know you can't you idiot you stupid
piece of poopie
oh you so stupid but you did wedge me in
here god damn it you wets that back in
there you sack of [ __ ] that was probably
my only way to victory
you piece up poopy I hate you the first
small glowing Jess do a bit of puzzle
solving and platforming then do I have
to you don't have to you don't have to
you don't have to I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine up this
ladder up this ladder up this ladder I
go what does he follow me up here I have
no idea did he give up yeah he gave up
cuz he's an idiot yes right oh okay
where am I what's with these minecraft
blocks oh hey how's your nose far out do
all right well that didn't help me Oh
what the Hitler Hitler is that Hitler
that might be dead
I think that's Hitler who's that Hitler
that my dad might be Hitler
I think that's Hitler yeah why is Hitler
up here
Oh Hitler please I don't know why you're
here I have no idea but okay all right
thank you for your interest but no no
sure oh [ __ ] had been grabbed oh thank
you I guess
oh I found what I've been grabbed I have
been grabbed by his big strong hands
it's it's gotta grab me I guess Wow
he's so big in his system all right was
this where am I now I have no idea it's
so funny okay
oh why why did that happen
I mean wasn't terribly scary but that's
why oh my god oh my god hey I've been
grabbed
I got webbed and I can oh yeah oh oh I
got a coupe all over me you were the one
that made that mess on the floor
you [ __ ] god damn you
god damn you oh you're still gonna be
there aren't you all right well then
come on grab me grab me with your big
strong nose there's nothing in any of
these there's no reason to go in any of
these this is a whole lot of nothing a
lot of dick a side order of diddly and a
whole lot of nothing there's the place
where I knocked it over but I can't go
oh ladder rungs don't do anything Hitler
come on all right so I got to get back
down and I gotta put these ladder rungs
on the ladder I think and then that'll
be good I guess where am I now
what is this place what is that oh oh oh
it's a laboratory Oates alibi Hitler no
unless your Frankenstein were you
Frankenstein Hitler dog no okay
or no Frankenstein's monster
Frankenstein's [ __ ]
it's Frankenstein's Hendler somebody
save me
oh well poop poop on my face okay
screw it screw it screw it screw it
screw it that's enough of that we get it
we get one short not so good gaming than
half of another game that's fine though
anyway so that was three and a half
scary games hope you guys enjoyed it
thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you everybody so much for
being here if you want to check out some
cool clothing
I've got cloak which is Sean and eyes
clothing brand you can check it out for
yourself it's got a lot of cool stuff
lots sold out right now we've got a
charity stream on December 1st be there
10 a.m. Pacific Standard Time everything
on my markiplier comm store on that date
will be sold for charity I won't make a
penny and you can help support a great
cause for Stand Up to Cancer thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]